thrilled to have back here on the rich
eisen show um getting ready for season
four of big mouth available for
streaming on netflix
uh it's released last week as a matter
of fact the co-creator and executive
producer and voice actor for many
different roles in this
very funny series big mouth welcome nick
kroll back to the show how you been nick
good rich how are you doing i am doing
fine we've been talking quite a bit
about fantasy football are you still in
one of those you're not because you're
i'm not uh i when when the league ended
i think i
it slipped away and then every year i
kind of wait for someone to invite me to
join [ __ ]
uh you know thinking i'm i would be like
oh
and but it's always like it's only
strangers on twitter
um and so i haven't i haven't joined um
so no so um would you
would you like to do one next year i
mean we'll invite you to one we could do
that well rich
you know i i appreciate the invite and i
will
now i'm gonna play hard to get and have
to consider it
but i feel yeah i feel like and i feel
like you're in you're in
in at least one league with some folks i
know i feel like
there's a at least that you were as a
couple years
no i'm still in i'm still in the league
uh with a bunch of poker buddies who i
definitely want to beat the pants off of
uh we may know some similar people right
there
um and and i we were just talking
earlier about how i want to win
so badly that when i'm losing i have to
sit down and
actually take stock in real life stuff
like my children
my marriage and just realize like you
know you know i mean i'm healthy
thank god you know like i i it's not
it's
it's not mentally it's not sane it's
basically what i'm saying does it help
but is it
is it this year especially with all the
insanity going on is it a helpful
distraction inside of it
oh my gosh yes it is no doubt about it
and i'm i still want to win and it's it
but it hasn't
balanced out the uh want to in terms of
being a sane individual
like it does not balance out the desire
to annihilate your close friends
right but you you know all about this
because you were in a series literally
about this sort of
um passion and insanity for all those
years nick
you know what i mean that's what
basically the league was all about
correct um yes that that that is
um that is what it truly was all about
him and it was
it was while we were doing it it was
super fun to
have um to have that kind of combination
of
of working with these people who then we
were literally in the league together
and
we would build end up building stories
around it like i was a
i was definitely the the term tinker
stinker
uh stinker tinker was was definitely me
it was the like
sunday morning you know 9 45
before the first kickoff slightly hung
over on the toilet
making some rash last minute decision
that's the best kind though yeah
you know like uh totally a total
combination
of the two um uh
tinker stinker yeah those last and then
also i was a drunk tinker i was
definitely like a late night
in bed oftentimes like saturday night
like a little drunk and then just making
some some
wild uh trades and last minute
substitutions
and then the next morning i think yeah
like would then be paying for both of
those things
on the toilet right before kickoff it
all comes back to the toilet doesn't it
nick if when it comes to it it really
does
it really does uh always if you're if
you're feeling if you're feeling regular
then you're feeling then you're feeling
good it helps clear your mind
make sane decisions you know who is the
best
uh football playing actor
or which you know that you have a couple
that
stand out um i mean the first one the my
first one was antonio gates i was in a
in a hot tub with antonio gates season
one
and i we we sh i was in a hot tub with
him for like five
hours and i was losing my mind and said
some things to him that i
don't remember and still regret um
uh terrell thugs very funny dude
um okay he's a genuinely funny guy
um uh jj watt
came in i'm this is what i realized like
this is
you know i'm sure you've dealt with this
too it's like the guys who are stars in
the league who then can transition into
being broadcasters
it's they're you have to be an
incredibly smart
like i know people i could be wrong but
i think a lot of people think that
athletes are just pure athletic machines
but to be the best at your sport let's
say like a jj watt to excel for the
number of years or terrell suggs
you have to your br your mind you have
to be
so fast and so quickly adaptable and be
able to learn and evolve very quickly
and i think he like i watched jj at the
beginning of the week
shoot one scene and then it was the week
of the espys and he probably shot like
two commercials
the next couple days and an sb sketch
and then came back on a friday and by
friday he was a markedly better
actor no kidding and i yeah and i think
it's
he's so a guy like that you know it's
like if you're
if you're the quarterback of your
defense or you're you know you're
you are learning picking up things and
adapting incredibly fast
and i think some of the for sure some of
the guys who came on
were able to do that um and
uh you know ocho cinco had four cell
phones on set when we were in vegas
um uh let's see
um i had yeah those are those are
definitely some of the some of the
highlights but it was it was always a
blast
i loved uh i always loved um having
um uh i always loved having uh
uh shoot it was just always fun no
matter who there josh cribs was fun
yeah i think didn't marshawn do one did
he do
john did a few marshawn came in in the
last minute and did it um
and was amazing um uh really special
very funny guy showed up late and
pranked the whole team
um uh uh
he he was uh he was just
very funny and like she pretended like
he wasn't gonna come and then showed up
uh like showed up didn't even tell his
agent and then showed up on set
um and then let's roll and then that's
right yeah that's fantastic yeah exactly
nick kroll here uh on the rich eisen
show uh okay
and big mouth is uh is back and um
and you've got so many funny people
doing this man so this season you've got
uh zach galifianakis and seth rogen and
john oliver how do you reach
paul gimmatti how do you reach out to
these people and say this is what i got
in mind for you
and then um and then this you then lay
out what you actually have in mind
for them nick well you know in in in
order of appearance john oliver was
early in the season he played the
british
we the first three episodes take place
at camp and
um we always had british councillors for
some reason like
i remember summer camps in the northeast
always had weird british counselors yes
high black socks and sandals and short
shorts yes
um yes including my now brother-in-law
roger bennett
uh who's a the men in blazers podcast
and tv show
um just a little just doing a little cr
sports
podcast uh show synergy shout out to
roger bennett
and uh michael davies of of the men and
blazers
crew yes um but they uh
those counselors are always around and
we john is a uh
a friend i i call him a friend i don't
know if he'd call me a friend but we
reached out to him he was down to pop in
and do it
um paul giumani voices a
speaking of toilet time uh one of the
story lines is that andrew goes to camp
and he doesn't like to poop anywhere but
at home
yeah and he basically spends the entire
summer holding it in uh
where he loses the threat a little bit
of a turtle head you know like a turtle
head situation where he pops out and
then
retreats and doesn't want to go back and
so paul
voices his impacted poop um
his angry impacted poop for the year um
and i think we reached out to him
directly or no i didn't reach out to him
we went
through regular caffeine i think it
turned out his his son was a fan and so
he was like all right i'll play an
impacted poop on yourself
um and
he's amazing i mean it's per it's he
couldn't be more perfect for the role
and then seth rogen has been a friend
for a long time and a fan of the show
and he plays my best friend at camp and
he was also a kind of a a camp kid so he
really understood that
um he played seth goldberg on the show
okay
his best friend from childhood and
writing partners evan goldberg my best
friend and
writing partner on big mouth is andrew
goldberg so we we thought there was some
fun stuff to make him
uh seth goldberg um and he definitely
showed his balls to kids at camp
on the show um and then
yeah zach galifianakis plays in fact
getting back to the
the beginning of our conversation he
plays the gratitude
um you know because the the season of
big mouth deals with anxiety
which i think people yes are dealing
with right now more than ever
kids are obviously dealing with it a
tremendous amount
and you know we talked to psychologist
therapists about how do you deal with
anxiety and
and the thing that came back repeatedly
and really with one specific therapist
that we talked to was he he talked about
you know take breathing really working
your breathing and also
gratitude and so when i heard gratitude
i was like oh what if there was a
gratitude
and um and then we reached out to zach
uh
who has this really wonderful kind of
funny voice for gratitude as like a kind
of a
fun almost like margaritaville-esque
gratitude you know this toad who's like
all about gratitude um
as a means to help kids deal with their
anxiety and as it means for you to deal
with your anxiety as you as you
losing your fantasy football yes and i
do need a gratitude you know
you're right you're right nick so you
just you just um
dropped a lot there and i just wanted to
i guess kind of want to go one by one on
a few things here
first of all i i went to uh summer camp
camp loconda trails end camp
both in uh uh new york and pennsylvania
respectively
and they did have tons of british
counselors
tons who all taught us
best they could about uh soccer playing
soccer
and i always remember and i made this
always my my
my call of soccer highlights on
sportscenter
whenever somebody just missed the goal i
would use the phrase that all the
counselors used with me which was
unlooking yeah
totally that's the word they would they
would call you unlucky
yeah and i brought that to sportscenter
because that was straight from my summer
camp experience
you know they they were they
of going like wide right and hearing
unlocked unlucky
hard luck that's what they would tell me
hard luck and i'd never heard
those phrases before being from staten
island new york and then so
your your brothers-in-law your
brother-in-law
the great roger bennett he's a he's a
stellar human being that guy
he is he's yeah he and i have obviously
he married my sister vanessa and
we did a book together years and years
ago called bar mitzvah disco
about his bar mitzvah pictures and
stories from the 70s the 90s
and he's gone on to you know is to to
host men and blazers and
and just become he's a sports fan i
think he's he's done a
ton to introduce premier league soccer
and and
to american audiences and figure out a
way to really connect
uh you know pop culture and sports in a
way and and
honestly in a way that you yourself
blaze the trail i think
in in in a way that that now has become
more more common but you know he's
really
dives in he's a great writer he's
written a lot of books and
and uh and and men and blazers if you're
interested in soccer if you don't really
care about tucker but you want to
understand it more
i i highly recommend oh man him and
davies are phenomenal and i do have
it's just it's not geographically sound
for me to get all the way up to where we
keep our mugs i do have a bilf life mug
that he gave me um because i'm amazing
i you know i i'm i'm i feel like i'm i'm
worthy of that mug
uh based on many different things uh and
i think you are thank you nick and then
and then last one
um look i i've i've been fortunate to
ask friends uh who are um very talented
and and very you know uh well-known
friends do stuff for me on this show
like hey would you mind reading it this
way or doing it that way and
and then they send it to you and it's
not that you know like
you you have to send it back to him and
say would you mind doing it another way
we've done
bits and constructs like that so when
you ask paul giumani to play an impacted
poop
do you just accept his first reading or
do you actually give somebody that
decorated
notes how does that work there
are there are not the beauty of paul
giamatti is that
there's not the need for many notes he's
really
he could really he was able to very
quickly
find a character okay of an impacted
angry poop um he in fact on my instagram
there's a video
um if there's a somewhere on my
instagram there's a picture of
of giamatti and then a video of him
you know i think we recorded him he was
in new york we were in la
and mark levin one of my co-creators
took a video of him speaking straight to
camera
about nick the character but i
i like to think paul is actually
speaking it directly to me but you can
see the performance
and it's it's pretty it's uh
it's pretty special um it's and
is this live are we live right we are
yeah we are
we are but i appreciate you giving me
that heads up but is
oh i could i could play something i
could play for you directly but i feel
like that might be
no that would be different slightly
dangerous we'll just have to
you know we'll just have to see it on on
your show yes it says
if you go to my instagram it's andrew's
poop is paul giamatti
and you can see it that the poop looks a
little like paul giamatti
um and and
and you can see paul and he's got a
fully shaved head
and it's it's pretty special
and if you're angry with me if we ever
end up in the same fantasy football
league sure
rich and you yes you get frustrated with
me
you can go and uh hear paul giamatti
speak to my selfishness and and and it
and and it might bring you some solace i
look forward to that nick and we will i
will
definitely uh remember that i've invited
you to something that you have months to
back out of
um year you know next year uh before
before i let you go uh for my own
children i need to ask
sing two is that coming do we get that
do you think more guys are coming
it's uh you know covid has thrown
everything sort of for a loop but it is
coming i've done a lot of
recordings for it and it's uh it's great
and i think i did a recording for you of
gunter
and i don't think i had you did not give
me any notes on it but maybe
no i didn't more comfortable no again um
you you captured that
but um if i asked you to record
something to my children in the voice of
the douche
um i would have given you notes for sure
from sausage
i will hold off on that but if and when
you need
if your kids are ever you know need to
make a bm
i can talk to paul giamatti about
voicing
an impacted poop for them you know just
let me know oh man i think i told you
the last time you hear my my kids
we were driving around town looked and
saw the the posters for sausage party
and billboards are like dad can we see
that i'm like
nope no you may not that's not
not yet no you may not when they do but
when they do it's a glory by the time
the coven quarantine is over oh my god
you'll be like you know what
go ahead why not watch it what are we
gonna do at this point we've watched
everything else
on every every streaming network at this
point nick this is great man thanks the
time
um let's do this more often and then you
be well you be healthy and safe
and congrats on your show being already
renewed for seasons five and six you can
catch big mouth
on netflix thanks for the call sir
thanks rich appreciate it right back at
you that's nick cruel
oh that's so damn funny
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here